I do want to take a moment though here
to mention a very special charity
mentioned it the other night I'd like to
mention it again called night of too
many stars all right this is an event
that raises funds to build schools
programs services to help the growing
population of autistic people who
desperately need them alright it airs on
Comedy Central
this Sunday October 21st at 8 o'clock
p.m. lots of huge celebrities are
helping out tip of the iceberg Jon
Stewart's hosting it Tina Fey Seth
Rogen's there Katy Perry Amy Poehler's
Stephen Colbert louis c.k the list goes
on and on and on and I want to do my
part I wanted to help out right and as I
mentioned the other night here's my idea
if we can reach our fundraising goal
before night of too many stars airs this
coming Sunday I will do an entire
episode of my show with a really
horrible and phony looking spray tan
okay [ __ ] and this is absolutely real
okay well I'll get the worst-looking
spray tan the Snooki is spray tan
available yes yeah I'm asking for the
snow - Snooki yeah yeah and we're not
talking just face and hands
[Music]
[Applause]
why did Nixon come in there no idea
anyway this is absolutely real I'll get
an entire body spray tan for a show and
if that weren't enough let me make one
more promise okay to get you even more
excited and sweeten the pot all right
not only lay do an entire show with a
hideous spray tan I'll also have my hair
completely done in cornrows entire show
that's my pledge is your your hair even
long enough to cornrow my hair will
cornrow very nicely Andy Richter if it's
too short I will not rule out some
extension okay I'll do what it takes so
if you want to help a wonderful cause
while simultaneously making me look like
a complete jackass please donate what
you can at team koco.com slash too many
stars or you can donate $10 just by
texting the word Conan to five zero five
five five that number again five zero
five five five do your part it's a good
cause
here this this will be 10
you can't see this home people recoil
this will all be a human skin color
finally you and I need x-rays someone
can just hold a flashlight behind here
all right all right see the bones